philadelphia i'll see you august 18th
through the 20th austin texas september
2nd through the 3rd that's labor day
weekend vancouver finally september 15th
through the 17th and edmonton i'll be
there september 29th through october 1st
get your tickets to those shows and all
shows on my website at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com and ryan sickler on all your
social media
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for your support i'm telling you we got
episodes coming the community continues
to grow if you are watching on youtube
please just hit subscribe it's a free
way to help the show and it definitely
[ __ ] helps us all right and if you've
got to have more then you got to check
out the patreon it's called the honeydew
with y'all all right it's five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free and i'm highlighting
the low lights with y'all if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard please submit the
honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and uh hopefully we'll get to do an
episode together you're also getting the
honeydew a day early you're getting it
ad free and you're getting it at no
additional cost all right
um
dates tour dates keep running on man
thank you for coming out guys philly
august 18th through the 20th austin
labor day weekend september 2nd through
the 3rd vancouver we're finally i'm i
think this is like two and a half years
in the making here uh september 15th
through the 17th now you guys know we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
always say that these are the stories
behind the storytellers i am very
excited to have this guest on here today
first time on the do ladies and
gentlemen please welcome jonah rosa
welcome to the honeydew job thanks buddy
thank you for being here good to be here
it's long overdue
uh no it's not it's not
it's not long overdue it is though no i
mean you started this
uh when i three years ago that was right
when i moved back to new york oh you
went okay so that's why it went back so
it's literally the exact and then it was
the pandemic this whole time so actually
we're kind of right on this is my first
trip back to l.a
since i moved to new york oh is that
right yeah i didn't know that i got here
yesterday this is the first work related
thing i'm doing
uh you hit me up this week thank you so
much
we're right on time all right yeah yeah
um plug promote everything you want to
plug
uh well actually this month i'm gonna be
in atlantic city at the atlantic city
comedy club uh and
next month i'm gonna be in san diego
uh and then i'm at the american comedy
company and then i'll be in at the dead
crow in october anyway i got a bunch of
dates coming up
check me out live please this is like me
being back on the road mentally for the
first time in three years uh oh you
haven't really been rolling at all no no
i'm going back out now uh i'm coming
right when the numbers are going up good
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] it
you waited all that time and they're
spiking again there ain't no way to win
[ __ ] it
uh
you know what i mean there's no winning
number you just gotta choose your losing
number so this is it i'm out there now
but uh no come on out uh i'm doing my
new hour it's called i never promised
you a rose garden it's a
full hour of hopeless comedy
anyway
joederosainfo.com for tickets and info
and all that stuff on shows but also i
opened a bar and sandwich shop in new
york city with my dear friend paul
italia it's called joey rose's it's on
the lower east side it's a social club
it's affordable drinks it's killer
sandwiches
eight sandwiches for eight bucks a piece
plus we got other things
in the subway yeah dude that's that's
the whole game
it's it's act you know what's funny it's
american gangster i was just watching
that when he gets the pure heroine and
he's like we're going to give them
double the product at half the cost
right and i was like oh that's what
we're trying to do with the sandwiches
so uh so uh
for the pure uncut sandwiches and cheap
drinks
come to joey roses please man it's the
the the influx outpouring of support
from the comedy community has been
amazing from the neighborhood it has
been amazing from new york it's been
amazing just come through we're open
tuesday
uh through sunday we open at 12 p.m
every day
uh
we're we're we're have it's a great time
it's a place you can go to and hang it's
a cool vibe everything
joeyrosesnyc.com
for all the info there and you know and
also if you want to order online and all
that stuff um have you and sal debated
on any of your sandwiches yet
no but sal
it's funny sal
you know because we do taste buds
together podcasts and sal and i um
we have a real kinship with food i know
i watch yeah that's that's where our
friendship
was born we were pals we're friends
friend we were we were teetering on true
friends
but when we started to talk about
[Applause]
[Laughter]
say
food
that's the food is what it
i know it's just you know it's funny to
hear a grown man say something innocent
right teetering on true friends um
the real friendship kicked in when we
started to talk about food our first
the first episode we ever did was chips
ahoy versus oreos and that was a real
heated argument we actually had
and when we were having it i remember
thinking like this is where we become
friends like like we're screaming about
cookies right now like and it's not as a
joke like we're really heated yeah i
watch you guys
so
a year later
two years later um
he he we were we were away we sometimes
we would take vacations and stuff
together
and uh
not just me and him
a bunch of us
[Laughter]
but uh
we were making breakfast and we started
arguing about bagels and that was our
second episode
and in the middle of the argument i mean
we were [ __ ] heated and we were
bringing everybody in the house in
on it
and then he just in the middle of it he
was just like
do you think this is a podcast and i was
like
yeah i think yeah
right
and i remember this this is
so funny these friendship moments you
remember that bring you such joy right
we were standing we were at a house out
out in the hamptons and we had a pool at
the house
and as soon as he said that we started
immediately we went into full
like work mode like what is it called
what is it called what is it called and
we were sitting in the living room it
was 10 30 in the morning we're going
back and forth
nah that that nah what about this
and he just looked at me and he goes
shouldn't we be discussing this with an
ice cold beer in the pool right now and
i was like i just lit up i mean that's
how you should work yeah and he he
walked across the room and hugged me and
he said don't you ever move to l.a ever
again and we went down to the pool
and we talked about it all day
and at 4 30 p.m i went
taste buds
and everybody was like
dad dude that's it i think and we were
like all right i think that's it and
then you know and then that's that's how
it started i could watch you argue over
a grilled cheese and a peanut butter and
jelly all [ __ ] day
thank you man thank you well thank you
for being here and something interesting
you know i ask everybody to come on with
stuff they'd like to talk about and then
where it goes it goes but
yours starts with adoption and that's i
do you talk about that in your stand up
i've i had i did i have
i sort of moved past it because the
stuff um
that i had to say about it
it's it's an interesting thing i talk
about it very indirectly a lot of what i
talk about
excuse me in my act when it comes to me
personally
stems from adoption
uh the stuff i talked about that
actually dealt with it head-on was not a
ton because i was adopted at nine days
old
nine days yeah it was a pretty clean
scenario uh-huh
you know there just wasn't a lot there
i've always known my parents they're my
parents i love them dearly you're
talking about your biological parents no
no no my fake parents
my friend
the people that gave their lives
sacrificed for the stranger
you're nine days old but you're still a
stranger the funniest
the funniest jokes about my adoption my
friends all made so i can't even make
them
because they're not mine but like my
friend brian english used to always go
i'd be on the phone with him and i'd be
like brian hold on my dad's calling me
and he'd go
fake dad yeah all right which always
made me laugh and then russ beneave
one of the funniest comics ever one of
my i love the guy so much he used to go
hey derosa
you think you think your real parents
are somewhere wiping their brow at the
bullet they dodge getting rid of you
you don't want to say that you go you're
going to derose it your adoptive parent
do you think they knew what a scumbag
they were inheriting
[Laughter]
all right which is the funniest thing
ever i love look i love it i you know my
pain and suffering has been from my dad
dying at 16 and i have a friend one day
just dropped it on me he's like hey ryan
your dad's still dead right and dude i'm
telling you i [ __ ] almost pissed my
pants so funny like the still dead just
is so good it's so good it's and j with
with the genuine delivery you know
one of my best pal scott um in my old
literally my oldest friend in the world
i've known him we our parents met
because they moved into the same
suburban neighborhood and my mom met his
mom while they were walking us in our
strollers no way and then they started
to hang out with me and scott as babies
and then we as we got older we kept
hanging out like so he's literally my
oldest friend in the world
but his dad died when he was 12. and i
i i make any [ __ ] joke i can about it
especially we love to play beer pong and
we talk a lot of [ __ ]
and i if i'm against him i'm always
bringing up the dead
every chance i can you should that's
what it's all about yes that's what this
show is all about
so what was the situation were you do
you know now like where was it
was your biological mom young was this
did they know that they were giving you
up to this specific family or were you
in a hospital that you were adopted by
how did it all happen for you um
okay so i actually know more than i'm
supposed to know because i guess they
used to be a little more fast and loose
with the information
but i know that one of my parents was
egyptian by blood and i know that one of
them was italian by blood but you don't
know which don't know which okay at
least that's what we were told i did
those dna tests later and found out that
i have no at least according to ancestry
italian blood in me it's all north
african and middle eastern it's all arab
blood really basically yeah so
one of them could have been italian but
they could have be they could have meant
he lived he grew up in italy but by
heritage he's actually egyptian or
whatever
so um
i knew that much they actually told my
parents the hospital i was adopted
who's that i was born in i mean excuse
me the agency and they weren't supposed
to
i mean you can you can trace
you could trace your parents easily at
that now the hospital i believe closed
which is a running theme in my life the
hospital i was born in is no longer
there the grade school i went to was no
longer there the high school i went to
is no longer there
and my college dissolved my major after
i graduated so
the universe does not want me to know my
past clearly like clear and it starts
with adoption it's a very odd
thing right
but um
even with knowing that information i
never really had an urge to go try to
figure out who they were you've never
met him never no oh really oh no no no
no all right so wait a second so let's
go back nine days old joe
was your name joe derosa are you born
joe derosa no no that was the name that
you don't i didn't have a name so for
nine days you're nameless yeah dude you
gotta do something with that
nine days you're nameless nine days
nameless and then and then is it the
derosas who adopt you is that okay so
they come in a married couple
my parents were married so this is a
very interesting story my parents are
married uh they still are my dad's a
deacon in the catholic church
is he yeah which is a step below priest
yeah
my mom
was a eucharistic minister at one point
but they're they're religious people
they're not shitty about it but that's
that's their deal and i respect it
um
they weren't in those positions when
they adopted me but they were religious
um because of their upbringing whatever
so they were pretty much following the
catholic rule book
they were on two adoption lists they
were on a
church
curated adoption list and then they were
on a secular list
from some outside organization
the church called them one day and said
we want you to remove
your name from all lists except for the
church list
and my parents said why and they said
because you need to believe the lord
will provide
and they said okay and they hung up and
secretly they were like no we're not
doing that we want to adopt a baby
the next day the secularist called them
and said we have a baby no way so had
they done that
i'm not you don't go to them yeah so who
knows
so
you know it's kind of a wild thing yeah
you know like i mean
it's it's not more wild than the chances
of your sperm fertilizing the egg and
all that [ __ ] but i mean it's as far as
well as ingrained as they are in the
catholic way it's that's a big deal for
them to
commit to saying [ __ ] that and then
luckily the next day so what happens
then what the catholic church finds out
that they get to get you they did they
just i think as far as their list i
think they just quietly removed from the
catholic list and that was the end of
that i don't think it's not like you you
can get sued or something you know what
i mean you're not accountable but they
weren't frowned upon and
i don't think it was the church i don't
think it was that personal i think it
was a much broader list for the diocese
diocese diocese
diocese diocese for the diocese i don't
think it was like their
next-door neighbor priest
you know what i mean like it was pretty
pretty broad all right now your parents
did they have any biological children
before you do they adopt any other kids
they were unable to have kids are you
their only child yeah yeah okay yeah so
being that they are religious
you know and i don't know how
seriously she means this but my mom has
often referred to them getting me as a
as their miracle and all that you know
because that's the way religious people
tend to talk
whether or not she believes it's truly a
miracle i i don't think so but i do
think she truly does think like this was
the lord's plan to bring us together
i don't believe in that sort of thing
but um but i will say if when you look
at the evidence it is kind of eerie you
know like the way the connection
happened look i was raised catholic my
grandmother all her sister we have a nun
well she passed sister carmina so it was
very catholic in my household the whole
time we're all fighting against it like
we i don't want to go to [ __ ] church
on sunday they're going saturday saying
the rosary i'm dropping her off picking
her up you know uh hail mary or whatever
it is our father at night you know the
beads and all that
and um yeah i i just
nothing made me
go against the catholic church way of
thinking right more than
them preaching it to me
yeah just so what i'm getting at is um i
know this sounds very la or california
but i
know fool there is definitely something
bigger
than us going on
yeah do i believe in this faceless
nameless sexless languageless
you know entity that
governs only this one tiny [ __ ]
particle of dust right in the entire
[ __ ] universe right now i don't
believe what i was taught by those
people right right but i do believe
in in a higher if we want to say power
sure love whatever you want to call it
sure there's definitely something bigger
than us going on i just don't believe
it's that [ __ ] no that's funny you
mentioned that because i'm just now
starting to re-explore
spirituality
not in a um
uh organized religion sense but i am
listening to some you know um to some
people of the cloth and and their books
and things like that and you know
um
it's funny because you ha
at least i have to it's kind of like a a
you know
like some people go to a.a because it
helps them but they have to look past
the god part of it right you know what i
mean and go i'm here for the bigger idea
that's kind of how i look at religious
stuff now i'm i'm listening more for
you know the connection between
meditation and prayer and how to connect
to the universe and and and how to
surrender yourself to the idea that none
of this really matters and
there's more to it and look it's
it's easier to say in stomach
the the the more prosperous you are the
easier it is
you know so it's
you know i i would always sort of hit a
wall with a guy like deepak chopra and i
i don't
i'm not knocking him i think he's a
pretty brilliant guy on many levels
um and i do think he's got a good heart
but like i'd see him and he'd have like
kind of gold diamond glasses talking
about like surrender yourself you know
what i'm like
well god damn dog you got gold glasses
on that's easy
you gotta look down on me with your gold
glue you know
but then i feel like when i say it
you know it's arrogant to somebody
you know what about the homeless guy in
the street like yeah man well there's
all of this matters come on man there's
always gonna be something yeah so it's
it's it's but i'm trying to get past
those things
so were you
did they have you in sunday school did
they i went to catholic school through
12th grade okay which is what turned me
off from a two yeah you know all right
but what age do you find out you're what
age do you find out your story i always
knew i was adopted i never remembered
them telling me
however my mom didn't tell me i was half
arab until i was 12. but so she did know
oh she knew yeah yeah yeah she didn't
tell me till i was 12. she told me i was
adopted
they from the beginning i don't remember
being told that i knew that my whole
life
but she didn't tell me the arab thing
till i was 12 and she was um
she was hesitant she was scared and i
don't blame her for this i think a lot
of people would misinterpret what i'm
about to say
but she told me and she told me
don't really talk about that
because we lived
in a
roman catholic irish catholic polish
catholic
suburb in pennsylvania everybody was
white everybody was the same religion
everybody thought the same thing i mean
it was it was the
the dictionary definition of suburbia
and you know
it's not that it was bad people there
were bad people there were a lot of
great people too
but i think she was very scared she was
very protective of me because of how i
because of their journey and trying to
have a child and then how i came to them
and all that stuff and i think um she
was scared
you can't be the one person who's not
like everybody else around here the arab
kid yeah because they're gonna do and i
was a bullied kid already
i was a bullied kid i had a tough time i
was you know why believe why look at me
but were you running your mouth or were
you just easy pickings at the time or
what was it i had a lot of
i always had a temper
always
i was always an emotional person i still
i still struggle with it
uh and i'm not somebody that's gonna
easily let it slide off his back i'm
gonna
look i was i did a show on san francisco
two nights ago
and i was like ten minutes in the crowd
was being tight and i was i was sitting
for the first ten minutes
and i leapt off the stool
and i go guys cut the [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now i'm doing a [ __ ] hour to loosen
the [ __ ] up stop it it's not my fault
your [ __ ] city's been overrun by
soulless [ __ ] techies
right and then they
and they were laughing like and it
opened it up because i have learned how
to kind of use it in a funny way
but i meant it
so like i'm not a guy that's going to be
like
you know hey man hey it's easy peasy man
hey no worries bro we'll get there when
we get there yeah
so when i was a kid
i i i i had a pretty strong tell when
something was bothering me and and so
kids that picked on me kept on picking
on me
and i was also um and i don't know why
this was i was kind of afraid of
physical
altercation
from a young age and i don't know
why i didn't have brothers i mean i've
been in a ton of fights yeah um
but going back i think everyone does i i
always did it's not until you get
[ __ ] punched in the face a couple
times and that you can take it and then
you realize all right that wasn't that
[ __ ] bad right it's not till that you
even taste a little bit of your own
[ __ ] blood you know your nose is
bleeding you're like all right
i'm still here
it's not i mean that's terrifying that
some
stranger
wants to [ __ ] you up yeah they don't
know you they don't know a thing about
you and they will absolutely kill you
some of these people yeah that's a wild
[ __ ] thought i was uh
you know i was look i i think for me it
probably stemmed
from my mom being a bit overprotective
so there was a lot of
you know
discussion of the of the potential
dangers of the world and all that
um
but we also were suckers for every
[ __ ] urban myth that came down the
pike you know
so you know don't go in those woods i
heard there's a dirt bike gang that
lives in there
[Laughter]
[Music]
i remember on halloween my mom not every
year but a couple years my mom taken
apart every piece of candy because of
the the thing about their they're
putting razor blades right yeah i
remember
my mom believed and told me the story of
the lady that wrote welcome to the world
of aids on the window or on the mirror
we believe that we believed them all the
the organs woke up in the
tub with ice yeah the liver was gone
yeah whatever that one was yeah all that
we believed them all so i think i was
just a f and then you put a layer of
true catholic uh guilt and whatever else
on top of that
where there's punishment for action and
all these things
i think i had a real fear of physical it
wasn't just physical confrontation it
was a fear of physical anything i had i
had
uh aids paranoia until i was in my 20s
because i felt like it was because i
felt like it was punishment for for
careless sex yeah not
magic johnson got it if you were uh
sexually active especially in that time
we're in our probably 20s yeah
it's terrifying i was i was about 16
when you died from the one thing i want
to do all the time when the johnson
thing hit i was about 16 and it was like
everybody and and
it was like see
it can happen to anybody yeah and then
easy [ __ ] me that's right because that
was a huge easy i was a big rap fan i
loved that's just a side note to what
we're talking about i was afraid of
confrontation but i loved
anything that was confrontational so i
was immediately attracted to gangster
rap and i got obsessed with it
i wanted to be in a [ __ ] gang i
wanted to carry a gun dirt bike gang's
right out back
they're right there i couldn't i didn't
know right
yeah
but i loved all that [ __ ] i loved as i
loved sinatra
because it was like [ __ ] you yeah no
yeah like
i loved all that [ __ ] and i it's funny i
i wanted to be around bad kids because i
knew that that was protection
it was also an acceptance you know
um
what was your dad like that's your mom
was overprotective what was your dad
like uh
my dad's a pretty gentle guy um
he's great they're both great i mean
you know uh
you know he was a stern father but not
you know i mean i grew up when you got
smacked man when you [ __ ] up you got
smacked you know yeah and i don't regret
it at all you know and i'm sure there's
people right now going well see that's
why you had a fear of physic it's not
it's not
uh because it wasn't excessive
but when i [ __ ] up
i called my mom a [ __ ] once oh my dad
my dad he put it to me pretty good do
you remember what he did
he had a belt
i think it was a stick
[Laughter]
he came home with that right broken off
outside the church when he was leaving
like i was dude i'll never forget he was
downstairs in the basement
he was in the basement
and he was doing something with a table
saw the [ __ ] table saw was going down
oh that's terrifying and and and my mom
said something i go stop being such a
[ __ ] how old are you
14 maybe i go stop being such a [ __ ]
and i heard the song go
and i was like
how the [ __ ] did he hear that and he
came up with a stick
whatever he was cutting
he gave it to me pretty good
that time
i tried to fight him once too yeah he
put that [ __ ] right to bed i talked
about that my i mean my like i said i
lost my dad at 16 but i think i was
about
14 or 15 when he's like you think you're
you're wrestling and [ __ ] now you think
you're a man i was like let's go it was
it was so bad right to the ground like
that
it was fast too i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
not ready
you know what's funny man is is
i have a friend it's a guy we both know
but i don't want to say his name because
i don't know if he's public with this
story but he's got teenage kids
and he told me a story of his at the
time
16 or 17 year old son trying to fight
him
and he said
he had to put it to bed because he goes
if this kid gets on top of me there is
going to be an irreversible power shift
in this household and that cannot happen
i have to be the father alpha
and it's like i was like damn dude i
never thought of it like that i just
thought of it like
if you want to be a punk you're going to
get smacked like a punk
i never thought of it like no dude you
don't understand
this is the person providing to the
child the child cannot overpower that
person
as
like you said alpha that's real wolf
pack [ __ ] it is wolf pack [ __ ] you know
that is set in dominance in the
household yeah yeah yeah cause if your
kid can take you and listen there are
some 16 year old kids that can whoop
their dad these these kids now biggest
[ __ ] ufc kid
if i have a kid that's a ufc kid i'm i
know i'm done the [ __ ] will snap
my shins i'm like
take the keys come back when you want
dude i had a nephew uh he's he passed
but uh he's sorry what happened i had a
drug problem it's a shame it's a shame
because i felt like he was a good kid
but he just was in in a bad way um but
that's a whole other story but uh but he
was a bad kid i don't mean i mean in his
heart he was a good kid but he was a bad
kid did bad things yeah
and he was living with my aunt who also
passed but it was his grandma because
his parents were all [ __ ] up
and uh
i was staying with her it was my uncle
died
so she lost her husband she's raising
her grandkid i mean it was just a bad
scene
and
my mom was like you gotta help aunt
sammy like she's like
anthony's putting her through it you
know and i remember he didn't want to go
to school he was already in
he was
he was already like
three times removed from regular school
he was in a goddamn yeah
yeah he was in like a hut in the woods
where they were like just color yeah
yeah just color we're just trying to
keep you up easy jail he's a coloring
book away from the dirt bike gang right
were just out there revving it waiting
for them
they're like god damn just keep this
[ __ ] kid off the street
he didn't have to do [ __ ] at school
he just had to be there that's all they
wanted
yeah yeah and i i sat with him all it
was it was a monday morning and the
night before i sat with him for like two
hours and really bonded with him and i
was like listen man you can't
it pops dead like you can't
don't give your grandma a hard time and
he was like i know i know and it was a
really cool
thing
and next morning he was just like [ __ ]
you i'm not going and just went back on
everything and i was yelling at him
he got in my face he was 14 i was
probably 30.
and i was like this kid could [ __ ] me up
like there wasn't a doubt in my mind
what happened to the nose
listen grandma you good luck
[Laughter]
i tried i'm out of here i don't know how
i finally got him to go to school you
did but i was like
i was i i was like this kid i'm not even
i can't no i had no place to get
physical with him i wouldn't have put my
hands on him
but i was like if he wants to go i'm
going to have a problem because he's he
there's a kid that like from the time he
was 11 was getting into fights
but here's the other night he was
trained at this point you know what i
mean street train yeah yeah street train
yeah there's a [ __ ] goddamn razor
blade hidden over in the bamboo bush in
the house you know
but also they're kids
so
you can't [ __ ] a kid up even if it's
your own kid you still can't [ __ ] them
up so it's like a i usually do a full
nelson or a pressure point i'm big on
pressure points right i used to [ __ ]
with my steps on all the time like he
would get me i'm like oh you're a big
bad [ __ ] now 11th grade huh and
i would just take my thumb and put it
right behind his ear right to the ground
like how about how bad are you i got i
got one fingertip on you bro you bad
you're bad
that's it but you can't you can't
[ __ ] snap a an arm or something
everything is getting more expensive gas
food travel including rent prices are
skyrocketing all over the country buying
a home might feel scary right now but it
could be your most stable option you're
guaranteed a fixed payment for the next
30 years i highly recommend checking out
the how to buy a home podcast you've
been hearing me talk about this for a
while now host david sidone is an
industry expert with years of experience
who's devoted to helping first-time home
buyers navigate this crazy marketplace
and he can help you too did you know
there's a difference between interest
rates and mortgage rates david will
break it all down for you how to buy a
home is an incredible resource you don't
even have to take notes full transcripts
of every episode are available at
howtobuyanhome.com david's how to buy a
home podcast has helped so many
listeners close on houses that they
thought were impossible even as things
went bonkers in 2021 and 22 and i'm
telling you people have come up to me at
shows and told me they bought their
first home because of this podcast so if
you're thinking about buying a home next
month next year in five years david can
help you too he can even connect you
with the great realtor in your area
start your path today with the how to
buy a home podcast and make this the
last year you rent listen to the how to
buy a home podcast today find how to buy
a home on youtube and wherever you
listen to podcasts
take action today for a healthier
tomorrow with everly well their at-home
lab tests vitamins and supplements can
help you get the best knowledge and
support you need so you can become a
healthier you everly well is digital
healthcare designed for you all at an
affordable and transparent price with
over 30 at-home lab tests you'll be able
to choose the test that makes the most
sense for you to get the answers you
need i took the food sensitivity test
and i'm doing pretty good man but it
makes sense why uh you know your boys
gotta run to the bathroom after i have
sushi it's that ginger y'all everly well
also has high quality vitamins and
supplements to support your overall
health including vitamin d3 and omega-3
fish oil here's how it works everly well
ships products straight to you with
everything needed in one package you
simply collect your sample you use the
included prepaid shipping label to mail
your test back to a certified lab your
physician review results get sent to
your phone or device in days you can
even share the results with your primary
care physician it's so simple over 1
million people have trusted everly well
to support their health and wellness
goals and you should too for listeners
of my show everly well is offering a
special discount of 20 off and at home
lab test at everlywell.com honeydew
that's
everlywell.com honeydew for 20 off your
next at home lab test
everlywell.com slash honeydew now let's
get back to the do
all right so your dad i can't even the
way my dad used to no smack me right you
couldn't do that now we got the belt one
time
all right i'll never forget it we got it
once i say we my brother i have a
fraternal twin brother
and he's four minutes older so
everything was that order derek ryan
todd that order right we got in trouble
that order we got fed you know yep
and i don't remember what we did
but my mom told my dad something and
this [ __ ] came home after a
double shift uh at national airlines
working for pan am
and took that belt off told us both get
on the bed
and here's the the real mind [ __ ] of
this
is i have to watch my brother i get it
no one this is coming you know what i
mean i'm like this is what's about to
happen to me so he gets to get hit and
go i gotta watch it get hit and go and i
am just you know putting my hands back
there and i'm getting the [ __ ]
the belt buckle on my knuckles and [ __ ]
brutal dude he did it one time and after
that
he felt so [ __ ] guilty he's like i'll
never he pulled us aside and apologized
like i'll never do that [ __ ] to again
but what he started doing after that was
he would get you right there on that and
he'd [ __ ] crank i mean crank on your
arm i'd be god damn it and it didn't
matter how big i was if he got me back
there i knew i couldn't turn around and
punch my dad cause he had already showed
me he could [ __ ] me up i got the belt my
mom would give me the belt sometimes mom
never never to buckle but she'd give me
and it was more like she'd chase after
me with it it wasn't like she'd put me
down and so it was enough that you
didn't want to [ __ ] up but it wasn't
like terrible
but i got the wooden spoon too yeah i've
had that and my cousin john my
my aunt sammy's son
i remember my parents were laughing one
day
i was like what's so funny they go aunt
sammy was hitting john with the wooden
spoon and he grabbed it from her and
broke it i was like holy [ __ ] you could
do that yeah that was like gangster [ __ ]
i was like wow man i got a brush one
time that broke over my ass from my mom
because she said you little you little
son of a [ __ ] and i said you're right
and i was in elementary school that's a
good call it was it was i knew i was on
the big things when i got that ass whoop
and i was like let's hurt her
that's funny my mom used to say i was
such a manipulative kid my mom used to
say son of a [ __ ] bastard cause that's
like an italian east coast thing and
then i said to her one day i go you know
what really hurts my feelings because i
am by definition a bastard i didn't give
a [ __ ]
yeah crying yeah she was like i'll never
say that again i'm so sorry
[ __ ] yeah that's great
that's great
all right
so you're adopted your mom your dad your
dad's a deacon
so he's working obviously he became a
deacon later in your life but through
your life he's working his way up he
well he no he didn't get into the
diaconate stuff so i was like in college
so what was he doing when you were in
middle school high school my dad worked
at sperry universe which was the first
company that it became unisys eventually
but that's very univac was the company
and created the first computer is that
right yeah he did engineering work there
and it was not
so funny you tell that to people and
they think like your dad's like bill
gates or some [ __ ] and it's like no
that's not what it was it was a
job that he busted his ass for
they treated him like garbage you know
he had to worry about layoffs every
other year and when he was in his 35th
year at the company they handed him his
papers and said take a [ __ ] hike no
yeah like and that's it like it was one
of those
i'm telling you dude we were
we were every
like every detail of the 80s suburban
american we were all of it my dad had
the thankless job that they booted him
up from with with you know without baton
and i after he put his whole life in my
parents head the house they were having
a hard time keeping up on the payments
with my mom had to work
uh i was a latchkey kid
it was everything dude it was that whole
[ __ ] okie doke that everybody fell
for in the 80s with the suburbs you know
we i said to my mom all the time we
should have never left the city we were
meant to be city people
and
you know my parents had massive credit
card debt
everything dude the whole [ __ ] thing
you know and it was just like we
i realized at a pretty early age like we
don't belong here
and i hated the suburbs i was a really
depressed kid i was really really sad
kid i had friends do you play sports
no because i was terrible at them and i
hated them
i always wanted to play music so that's
what i did and my parents were very
supportive they didn't make me play
sports
they didn't push me to do anything that
i didn't like doing
uh they nurtured me with music they they
you know that it was great but i was
into music
and i was into and i was
very intrigued by music that spoke of
another life that i wanted
you know it started with hip-hop and
just the talk of the city and all that
stuff and i just the deeper i got and
you know into music and and then came
like
heavy metal and punk rock and and and
all these things where i was i was
hearing about these this other world
that was out there somewhere
and i remember
and i and i say this with all
seriousness i remember
when i first got introduced to porn
thinking the same thing
thinking
there are like women out there that are
like okay with sex and like
you don't because i lived in this place
where every [ __ ] person was married
nobody was single you know and i lived
in that area in my early 20s still
and there were just no options
and i remember my friend saying well i
remember it was like when internet porn
first happened my friend saying like
that's fake dude there are chicks out
there and i was like you're [ __ ]
wrong dude we're living in
we're waiting to die in this place man
like it's all right if you got a family
and you want to raise your family here
and it's nice but i'm like
we're 21 years old dude we're going to a
bar and it's all older married couples
there's like a world out there for us
like
and
and i just was obsessed from that
obsessed with that from a very very
early age i was a depressed kid i
remember very distinctly being woken up
for the first day of school in third
grade
and and very consciously thinking i
can't believe i have to go through
another year of this
[Music]
like i was just done dude i just i
hated it i hated school i hated church i
hated where we lived
yeah
i hated it i hated it i loved my friends
but even with that we had such limited
access to anything you know like did you
date at all in high school and and i
asked that for two reasons one you're
describing how you were in high school
but the other one is you have a very
religious catholic family so
how was were you allowed to bring girls
home
i had a low homecomings problems yeah
parents were okay were they all were
they practice safe sex or not talk about
it at all
it was sex before marriage was founded
right uh so we didn't really talk much
about sex but but they did teach me
the basics but they taught me the basics
like but don't ever do this yeah right
right my school certainly didn't teach
it to me
you know
but um they uh yeah i was allowed to
date i dated uh but i i was i was not
good at it until
my senior year in high school
because i never
um
i had very low self-esteem
i had very very low self-esteem and i
was afraid to approach
uh women
and it manifested in me in a negative
way
as as all relationships do it wasn't a
thing that was pointed towards women
it was a thing that i had pointed
towards people i had really severe
abandonment issues
that comes from that subliminal thing
that comes from adoption
uh
[Music]
and then you put in
you you know that combined with all the
catholic stuff combined with my parents
being a bit overprotective and all that
stuff
i i had really bad rejection issues and
and stuff so when somebody
slighted me or treated me poorly which
is much crueler
directly crueler when you're younger
i was like i wanted to see [ __ ] blood
you know what i mean
uh and i just it was just [ __ ] i carried
for a long time and it affected my
ability to approach and date girls too
because i felt like i wasn't [ __ ] you
know what i mean
uh and i didn't have any confidence
and it wasn't until i started playing in
bands which was my the tail end of my
junior year
that i started to realize like oh like i
can talk to girls because i suddenly did
something that was kind of cool that
made them talk to me
that made a girl that i thought was cool
say like hey i like that thing you did
and now suddenly i had some chips on the
table right yeah
and that got
that went
a thousand-fold when i started doing
comedy because i still had the
self-esteem issues but i was able to
navigate them enough that i was dating
and stuff to an extent
but i remember when i started doing
stand-up i was still really intimidated
when it came to women and uh bro rocco
stow you know rocco brian still
he's a comic out here in la uh and he's
a guy i started out with in philly
but he goes come on dude he's like it's
and he was always good with chicks he
was just always good with it he was that
guy he was like travolta in saturday
night faber you know
and he was i remember he said to me he
goes it's just like when you're up on
stage man
like why is your confidence leave you
when you leave the stage and i was like
i don't know dude but he was like he
kind of like
like uh
what's that movie hitch with will smith
yeah he was like my hitch you know where
he kind of taught me how to have
confidence and then all of a sudden i
just i realized like oh no it's beyond
it's i'm putting such a focus i'm
focusing on all the wrong stuff you know
i'm focusing on all the wrong details if
i just have confidence
there's something here that i can share
with somebody else you know
so that's that's how that went well let
me ask you why have you not uh ever
sought out your biological parents
what is it that you i don't know do you
feel like you're cheating on your
parents a little bit yeah have have they
ever told you they'd be cool with it or
100 i was going to say i'm sure they are
they sound like a great uh they're 100
supportive uh have you done a 23andme
yep so do you have other siblings no
that you know at least that you know of
right because how does that work you
have to other people have to put their
info in as well yeah i i i did both i
did i did ancestry and 23andme and uh i
think there's a third one now but um
but uh no one else pops up like fifth
cousins fourth cousins i don't think i
ever got past fourth cousin
you know who cares right but like
no i just never looked
i had one therapist tell me that i need
to why need
she said you're like the beginning of
your life is a huge question mark
looming over it and you should go figure
out who these people are and i i didn't
really agree with her i i understand
that you know
and it also can go two ways i answered
in nine days it's not that big of a
question where it could have been just a
young mom who couldn't take care of you
it could have been a lot of don't get it
twisted dude like and this is one of the
things i used to joke about in my act
but everybody thinks it's going to be
[ __ ] field of dreams
where you know your dad goes want to
play catch you know and all that there's
horror stories dude
there's [ __ ] horror stories
you know it's a gamble and i i don't
really want to make the game
these people are giving up a baby in
their teens chances are they didn't make
the right decisions
it didn't start out great for them
chances are this that's i was the start
of the dominoes falling you probably
were
you probably were dude
or
they figured it out they've got this
[ __ ] suburb life with three great
kids and joe's just out there somewhere
you know it's funny man i'm now trying
to talk about
and it's not i can't figure out how to
get it to work
uh
but i'm a pro-choice guy and as an
adopted person that's kind of an
interesting take because it could have
went the other way on me
uh
but
you know i try to be selfless in that
department and say well well for me sure
you know but christ
my thing worked out a lot of people's
whatever
but i'm a protrusive but i keep trying
to figure out how to work a bit about
like
because you always hear if it wasn't for
abortion that you know xyz
i'm like but if it was for abortion i
wouldn't be here yeah so like it's an
interesting weird
like you know conflict that you have uh
you know but um
i don't know you know
i i guess i just and and maybe one of
the reasons i don't
i can't figure out how to make it work
is because i almost don't really believe
it i don't see myself as somebody that
didn't come from my parents yeah i can
get the i mean i just your memory's not
even formed at nine days yeah
i just feel like i'm their blood and
like and i resemble them in certain ways
yeah and like emotionally physically
you know remember my friend scott again
his mom telling me she's like i can't
believe you're adopted you look just
like here you know like
it's not like a weird
it's not like different strokes where
you're like
kids don't
look like the dad
two of these kids
you know but uh it's like i i don't know
man i just
you know and my great regret
my great regret was my parents were
gonna adopt a second kid they were yeah
they wanted to adopt an asian kid how
old were you i was pretty
10 you less young boy or girl
i don't know but they asked me if i
would feel comfortable with it and i
said i didn't feel comfortable with it
because i couldn't process at that time
having a a sibling that didn't look like
me you know what i'm saying i couldn't
and i can't say it's a regret i was a
[ __ ] kid you know what i mean yeah
and like
you could argue that my parents
shouldn't have posed that question to me
or you can argue that they were being
great parents by saying we want to
discuss this with our child they were
like we just wanted to know how you were
felt about having another sibling not
whether he was eight
your [ __ ] is
they're like how do you feel about a
brother
i feel terrible though
i'm good
yeah what if they said hey
it's a white kid would you have said
yeah or was it more about i would have
only
been thrilled you would have i can't
like
isn't that [ __ ] up well not at 10 like
like but i mean like or i might have
been a little younger than that but like
it's it's but my point is like isn't
that weird that at that
that's why i don't buy
look i'm not saying i was an evil person
a child can't process certain things
that are pretty when you get older well
also let's go to your defense here
because also at this age now where you
are you're surrounded by nothing but the
same kind of people
you are and here you are already being
told well you haven't been told not to
talk about being arab yet maybe maybe it
was around that asian kid time that your
mom's like you know what we might let
him know
yeah they want to let him know he's
different yeah before he starts
cutting half of his body
but uh yeah um but it's interesting
because yeah it's you can't i couldn't
and i ugh i it regrets not the right
word you can't regret something like
that but
i wish i would have thought otherwise
and who knows my parents honestly it was
for the best my parents couldn't have
afforded to take on another kid
and
maybe they were just asking me very
passively you know it's something i
should probably discuss with them at
some point
but i don't think it wasn't like they
were
at the place
right holding the call on you like with
the phone yeah
we're bringing them home
yeah
so
and you know and i might be mis
remembering it might have been a foster
situation i don't remember but uh
you know it's honestly it's probably for
the best but um
but you know that would have been kind
of cool
to have a sibling you know which my
cousin danielle i was going to ask do
you have close cousins or anything like
that well we've had a lot of death in my
family
sadly we had a big family
and holidays and everything are big big
celebrations 20 people
and everybody it's it's very very sad my
uncle
so first my grandfather died
then my uncle john died
then my nana died then my aunt sammy
died no no that my aunt enoch had died
how long were we talking about in all
this
five years jesus was a huge blessing
just awesome yeah so auntie anika died
then aunt sammy died
then my uncle brian who was married to
so aunt sammy and uncle john they were
married both dead uncle brian
or my cousin sarah his daughter
she moved away got married moved to
georgia then my uncle brian moved down
south
so dude our family went from like this
to like so holidays now are me and my
parents my cousin chris and will
that their dad's my uncle brian
and then my cousin danielle and her
husband and her
her kids
uh
and my cousin danielle her parents were
michael john man sammy so
um
she has become
like a sister figure for me
because her parents are gone my parents
live near them
so they step in for their her daughter
when they have like grandparents day or
something my parents go that's nice um
and it's become
it's just a new family it's like we now
have this thing that feels a little more
like this is me and my sister and her
kids and my parents you know
um
but they call you uncle
yeah which is nice because i don't have
siblings so you know dylan is her son
and he's he's old now he's married now
but he's 20 i think 22 but he's they
come they come watch you do stand up
stuff he hasn't because he he went into
the military before
basically right when he was old enough
to finally start coming to shows he went
to the military so he's seen me do
stand-up on tv and [ __ ] but he doesn't
come danielle and her husband will come
ava her daughter's too little about your
parents in fact ava asked to watch me
and she's like my cousin's like no
yeah yeah my parents come all the time
and then have you ever done material
about adoption and stuff in front of
your parents yeah they think it's funny
yeah and they think my stuff about the
catholic church is funny oh that's good
yeah i don't really do it anymore but i
used to yeah i used to do a thing about
jesus uh
it's funny most catholics in the
audience would get mad my dad loved the
thought my dad thought the bit was
hilarious i said think about jesus
people
having the audacity to pray
to jesus you know like like i lost my
wallet you know or i got mugged why is
this world so cruel and that i would do
jesus reacting like
you know they they
beat me
until i had a prolapsed [ __ ] i'm
gonna wear me your [ __ ] wallet man
the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] you know
and catholic people always get real mad
uh but my dad thought it was funny
because my dad got it my dad is very
religious right but he's righteous
he's truly righteous
because he's like
no i
that's a pro-jesus joke you know what i
mean like sometimes i was just watching
a clip of sam morell talking about like
he did an abortion joke but it was a
pro-woman joke but the woman cried you
know what i mean and got offended by it
like
it's interesting to see that with my dad
like his and my mom used to kind of
nudge me to go back to the church and my
dad said to her one day after many years
of this and us arguing about it leave
him alone we found our path he has to
find his that's righteous
and my mom is righteous too
my dad
i think got there a little sooner than
she did
which is okay we're all growing you know
and i was no angel in those exchanges
either but
but they're they're truly
i i admire that you know
they're not running around saying
you know gay people are wrong right and
this and that they're not doing any of
that you know like they're just trying
to live
like a guy they admire lived you know
what i mean
so i think that's actually very cool i
uh i love it yeah do you um do you want
kids
[ __ ] no no [ __ ] no like you really don't
or you just they hadn't happened i can't
think of a greater hell
when you texted me today you were like
i'm just getting my daughter off the
camp i was like oh geez
i was like man i want a muffin get
somebody don't have to camp i think i
got her off the camera it was a
[ __ ] today's it was day one
we're at the back like you're at the
teachers lot i'm like yeah but we're
right here can you just let us in the
gate you know and they're like no you
can't let you in the gate you got to go
to the front i'm like can we walk around
like you got to drive like they blocked
the street off she's like you gotta go
to the other i'm like goddamn
go around enter him yeah i'm out there
banging like hey we're here you know i
can't i mean here i love it though i
mean
i'm sure it's beautiful
i mean i'm sure i'm joking you know what
i mean i'm not joking i'm joking i'm not
joking i know but you're sure you don't
want to be a parent i
opened a bar mm-hmm
i'm connected to this [ __ ] place i
can't just cut and run
and the commitment of that
is at times quite overwhelming i can't
imagine if it was a living breathing
person because even with a business like
this bar is the biggest thing i've ever
undertaken in my life
in my life
it is the biggest commitment i've ever
made ever
and it's not just to this
space
it's to my partner
my business partner
it's to
the customers
it's to your staff
there's so much you have to come through
on for people
and hey man at the very least
it's x number of years on that lease
right
i
i
and it's it's it's fulfilling and
gratifying and terrifying it's a lot of
different things
but i still know
that god forbid if it were all to not
work out eventually
it just goes away
if all went wrong and it didn't work you
go okay all right we tried we tried our
best
with a kid there is no it goes away and
i just can't fathom that commitment i
can't fathom it i can barely fathom it
in a marriage sense
to be with somebody okay so let's go to
that real quick you're open to being
married but even not having a kid
my dream what i truly want i want to be
in a committed relationship
without marriage without getting the
state involved
i hear you loud and clear yeah but a
committed relationship we can have a
ceremony where we commit to one another
but i'm not getting the [ __ ] are you
doing it you're not doing it at church
then just gonna do a ceremony
i'm not doing anything that makes it
official agreed
i agree what i'm saying
but
i just need some thumbs up no wet
signatures
[Laughter]
seen some people go through it you know
and i'm like i don't
[ __ ] that dude so anyway but um
i'm i'm all for commitment
but i want us to live in separate places
not cities separate
homes yes
i think it's i think you want a
girlfriend
yeah there's no wife that's gonna do
that [ __ ] well i disagree
i feel like those kind of wives are the
women that have been with their husband
for 20 years and they're like we're just
we just don't feel like doing the
paperwork to get this [ __ ] undone and
i'm going to live over here well
here's why i think i have a pretty
rational argument for this
i think it is so hard to find somebody
you can commit yourself to in that sense
and then you want to put cohabitation on
the table it's forget it
how many friends do you have
your best friends
the people you're closest with
but you're like if i lived with this
person i would [ __ ] kill them
because living together is i'm not
saying we don't stay together i'm not
saying we don't spend the weekend in our
place or his play or her place whatever
i'm just saying
you need that you need to be able to get
away
because something stupid like the way
you leave the bathroom
that to me can spark a fuse that it's
just too much
why are we you know it's like i can't so
where does that anxiety come from
because you didn't grow up in that
environment you grew up in what scene
what was your parents a loving marriage
were they good with each other
affectionate in front of you hugs things
like that
they're very affectionate and i'm very
affectionate with that you know my dad's
dad
was
a good man but callous
i tried to hug my grandfather once and
he said you hug women you don't hug men
no yes
damn when my well that ain't [ __ ] when
my dad went to vietnam my grandfather
shook his hand and said come home safe
no he never said i love you not a hug
going to vietnam dude come home
oh god
man that is some [ __ ] right [ __ ] up
that's really [ __ ] up so my dad was in
turn very affectionate
i hug and kiss my dad every time
my mom's father
was
in in certain ways a good man but he was
abusive
and uh again she went the other way with
it she was like i'm not gonna ever let
my kid go through what i went through
so um
so they're affectionate they're
affectionate with me they're affection
without it doesn't mean we're not loud
we argue we're a loud family but my
whole family's loud
you know it's not unusual for a big
if you watch like the old woody allen
movies where he shows his family at like
passover that's you know that's like
kind of how my family is so um
[Music]
um so wait where's oh oh why where's
that anxiety come from to not want to
coexist or cohabitate right
it's not i wouldn't call it anxiety it's
i've lived with people and i have almost
always resented those people
and you are you talking roommates as
well or are we just talking about no no
no roommates
i'm not wrong i'm talking about moving
in with your boys like moving in with
your people
dudes you take a bullet for
and a year in you're like i gotta move
out man you don't know how to [ __ ]
respect
somebody you're like fill the [ __ ]
ice cube trays man
you know what i'm saying
so yeah
if i meet the love of my life
you can't tell
[Laughter]
so if i meet the love of my life why am
i bringing that into it why
honey you got your place live however
you want to live there i'll live in my
place so i want to live and you come
stay with me and i'll come stay with you
but here's the difference when i come
stay with you
and you got
tupperware in the same cabinet as spoons
and bowls
i'm like
you got a goofy-ass kitchen
not my problem yeah
i'm not like what the [ __ ] you know
it's a fight that just doesn't need to
happen
somewhere
[Music]
i can't take [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah
tupperware is its own [ __ ]
drawer okay absolutely includes cool
whip containers and [ __ ] too it goes
down there yeah but also oh god let me
flip it the other way
she shouldn't have to deal with me
being like the four remotes go right
here at all times
your wallet is never on the coffee table
your wallet goes on top of the bookshelf
you know what i mean like i have my way
of doing [ __ ] because it's my system
i like to here's here's something
i really like to go to sleep to
my ipad or to audiobooks or whatever
people have sleep rituals that help them
sleep
you don't need to [ __ ] that up
because the other person can't sleep
that way or whatever it is or they have
their thing that you can't stand you
know i dated a girl once that was like
i have in order to sleep i have to put
she had a fan like on a
i don't know it was like on the wall or
whatever but it had like an extension
arm she's like i have to blast it in
directly into my face full blast and
then lay under the
four blankets
so i'm cold but i'm making myself warm
she's like that's the only way i can
sleep i'm like now if i married that
woman
you got to be like look you gotta go
i don't want to [ __ ] up your sleep sleep
we don't need to it doesn't need to be
24 7.
you know what i'm saying
are you open to your own bedroom in the
same house
it's that tupperware and silverware
isn't it it just goes beyond the west
awareness
where the stairs yeah yeah
it goes beyond the kitchen
[Laughter]
it goes beyond the kitchen i love like
like you we're talking about me and sal
earlier right i love sal man sal is is
my man i i'm i'm lucky
to have met
a friend that great in my 40s yes i mean
that's it's crazy
um
we're tight as hell
if i lived with sal i'd i'd murder him
yeah you guys sounds real big on you
gotta take your shoes off when you come
in the house [ __ ] like that i'm like dog
i can't do this man you know what i'm
saying
so why ever you know what i'm saying
like it's like
i love that dude i i don't his bathroom
habits don't need to come into this
do it
i'll do mine and we're cool i sneezed on
this floor the other day i mean the guy
was gonna have a [ __ ] stroke
it's on an episode of coming out of
taste buds
i panicked and i sneezed away from him
panicked you tried to respect that yeah
you know he's like this i didn't cover
up because i panicked and he's like dude
he talked to me about it for 20 minutes
he's like what do you do i don't
understand i understand this you know
the sneezes i'm like don't dude i could
you could you live with that no i
couldn't live with that he's one of my
best friends yeah
you know so like
there's just a lot that comes into
cohabitation that i think i think it's i
of course i think it's progressive
because it's my idea
or what i believe in at least
but i do think it is progressive i think
it's good yeah listen here's the thing
if you really take a look i'm sitting
here thinking about your life as we're
talking about this you have
a podcast with sal that you can go to
work together have fun leave you got the
restaurant with paul you go too you work
together you leave you seem to have
built your
relationships in exactly the manner
you're talking about although they're
not romantic they're
relationships nonetheless and it seems
like
you've stayed true to your structure
there i need my space man
paul italia my business partner and one
of my best friends i'm lucky to be able
to say that about people ari shafir
makes fun of me for it he goes you say
dear friend too much
and i go no i don't i have a lot of dear
friends ari
you know maybe because i don't say
psychotic [ __ ] on twitter and drug them
in front of her
i go ari i have many dear friends
because i don't dose them or say crazy
[ __ ] on twitter
he's like okay okay
[Laughter]
but paul you know like i call i'm having
a i'm having a lot of problems with my i
bought a jeep and i bought it used as is
and i'm having a lot of problems with it
and i had a major thing with it right
before i left for this trip
and i was talking to my dad about it
because i was kind of freaking out you
know and i was i was just venting to my
dad and my dad's like i wish i could
help you i don't know what to do i was
like there's nothing anybody can do
don't worry about it
and then paul called me and this is like
touching man
he called me he's like
give me the number the mechanic while
you're gone i'm gonna go take care of
your jeep because i think these guys
might be [ __ ] around with you right
now
and i called my dad and i told him that
and my dad was like a friend like that
is one in a million and i was like yeah
i know you know that's lucky yeah i love
this [ __ ]
i couldn't live with him
all right we're gonna end right there
that was great now hold on though yeah
your first time here i told you at the
beginning
going back listening to everything we've
talked about what advice would you give
sixteen-year-old joe
i got out running to the wire i almost
teared up talking about how my friend
paul i saw
i saw
and then dropped it with a joke that's
how this this this is what that show is
god damn it 16 year old me um
honestly yes to the asian brother yes
yeah say yes
revisit the asian brother
honestly man i would just say
don't put so much of your self-worth in
other people
it seems at this age that that's what it
is but that's not what it is and the
second you stop doing that the sooner
you're gonna start to have a good life
uh because that's not something i
learned until i was like i said it was
it was like in i was doing comedy
that's when i started to realize i had
something to offer because i could do
this thing
and then as i
did that thing
and uh
met people through doing that thing
because now all of a sudden there was a
connecting thing right oh you're funny
whether it was another comic whatever
i realized oh there's a lot more
to me too that i can also offer you know
what i mean
so
it's
that's what i would say
it's it's
you know you might have a hard time
figuring out how to make the connection
but don't put your value in all the
people around you
that's [ __ ] well said
yeah
especially because a lot of them are
going to tell you you can't right um
most of them are going to tell you no no
yeah i got to tell you when i look back
on how many people told me i can't
and i'm a spiteful dude
i mean i had teachers
i had teachers theater teachers i was a
theater minor and i get it if you're not
a major
they got to give the kids that are
majoring in at the stuff first
but i couldn't get respect
uh from my theater teachers and a lot of
my fellow theater students
and i'm like if i would have listened to
these people i never would have been on
any tv shows you know what i'm saying
so but it [ __ ] you up at the time you
want the professor to tell you you're
good and you're putting all of your
worth in his
opinion
don't self-approval yeah that's it
that's a little secret that's great
thank you for doing this thanks man um
plug everything again please
all right joey roses new york city
sandwich shop bar social club great time
come on down and see us we're open
tuesday through sunday we open at 12 p.m
every day we fresh bake the bread every
day come through i'm telling you you
won't come when i come to new york i'm
coming please
have a great time and by the way you
have eight sandwiches for eight dollars
you and sal should absolutely debate him
on [ __ ] taste buds well i can't have
him
i mean i can't do a thing where somebody
might say a negative thing
just talk about why he likes that one
better yeah okay fair enough fair enough
it's got to be all positive but we've
we've brought him on taste buds and
stuff
and sal thankfully loves them all but
come through you won't be disappointed
joeyrosesnyc.com for all your
information
uh and you can also order uh directly
through our website there if you want
and then all my upcoming live dates real
quick do you ship
we don't ship yet we're getting you will
alright yeah we will we will we're going
to get into gold belly and all that
we're just
you know trying to lay the foundation
first
um and then uh uh all my live dates
starting with atlantic city this month
uh go to
joederosainfo.com for tickets and show
information
joe derosa comedy on instagram and
twitter
and the podcasts are taste buds and
we'll see you in hell
thank you
happy birthday week thanks buddy you got
it and as always ryan zickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you